i started to notice this that as i have
more responsibility on the job
as i do more amazing things that i'm
enjoying of
and i becoming even a better mom so even
if i'm one hour less with them
when i am with them i am like much there
i am much more fulfilled i'm having much
more fun with them i
appreciate the time that i have with
them welcome to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc found in silicon
valley
in partnership with leomi tech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
what is it like to join a 200 person
organization as the seventh employee in
israel
and seed grow to over 1800 employees
becoming vice president along the way
well this is today's story meet tal ras
of vp product growth at zoom info
talk has vp product growth zoom info a
leading go-to-market intelligence
platform that arms
sales marketing and recruiting teams
with the data insights and technology to
help them target their next best
customers
with the right messages at the right
times tal joined zoom in for four and a
half years ago as a marketing analyst
when the today 1800 employee company had
nearly 200 employees
seven of them in israel talgaz welcome
to 20 minute leaders good morning
hi mike how are you i am doing excellent
i'm really excited to
hear from the vp of product growth tile
at zoom info
uh you've joined the company i believe
four and a half years ago when it was
just 200 people today were over 1800
and so i'm excited to hear you know from
your perspective what is it like to be
in this in this incredible a company
talking about product talking about
sales a lot of numbers that are involved
but also your your own journey
and obviously with zoom in for being one
of the most successful ipos
of 2020 and a big big pride in the
israeli tech scene and uh and i'm just
genuinely excited tell me a little bit
about yourself
what happened four years ago also when
you when you joined zoom info
um sure so again it's really great to be
here i'm really excited and for sure
it's been quite of a journey
and really looking forward for what the
future is holding for us
and it's just the beginning four and a
half years but every day feels like it's
a new beginning
and so yeah i started i i joined zuma i
was the seventh employee at the israeli
side today we are
280 and my role wasn't really
defined it was more of an we are
starting to hiring in israel we know you
from the past
come join us and we will do great things
together and it's exactly
it's exactly describe the first few
months
of my role it was understanding
who we are what we are doing and setting
the goals it was really focused on the
marketing
organization and translating the
marketing initiatives to numbers
tracking them and finding opportunities
and also finding
problems and usually numbers will
reflect you
if if there are problems and and
if at first um basically we were finding
problems and fixing them and by that
creating opportunities
and about um six months
after i joined zominfo and we had our
first acquisition
yeah you want to ask something i well
you know
we're talking about numbers and we're
and you know throughout the conversation
obviously
zoom info is going to be a big part what
what is zoom info
for for those who don't know because it
is a very major
stakeholder especially when we're
talking about products and sales and
numbers
especially as we're as we're in the
middle of 2021 what what is zoom info
in a few words
sure so zoom info it's an intelligent
platform
and with business information about
companies and about people inside those
companies
and what we do with that huge database
that we have
is that we are delivering it to our
customers
in the most sophisticated ways wherever
they are and helping them um
with 360 um degrees support
and to go to market and the main focus
currently
is sales we are expanding to additional
markets but basically
sales departments can find inside zoom
info
everything that they need to reach to
their next customer everything that they
need to expand inside existing customers
and intelligence uh every data that you
can think about that can help you that
can
save you time um and helping you
focus on on selling on talking with your
customers on reaching to them on
breaking the ice with them
right and so today obviously we're
living in a world where you know
ultra hyper connectedness uh probably
anyone's linkedin from the industry is
filled with
you know for every interesting message
there's about 10 sales messages
that are very non-personalized and
they're and and most of the time you're
thinking why did why did they even write
to me
right and so what is really the pain
point in this hyper
connected world that zoom info comes and
says we think we can deliver
better information to guide you to the
right people what what is actually
happening especially over the last five
years that also made this
made this the right timing for a company
like zoom info
yeah so our data is gathered from
multiple data sources and not just one
so for example linkedin
you are in charge on the data that
linkedin has
on your right you are the one that
updates it and you can
not update it for five years or you can
update it every day
zoom in for gathered its data from
multiple data sources
and it matches it and it's comparing it
and it's making sure to always have the
most
updated data and we give you data not
only about the person we also give you
data about the company
so if it's intense data about
who are they interested in if it's
technology data what technologies this
company is
is using if it scoops if it's promotions
if it's funding
um everything that you can think about
that can
help you personalize the message to the
people that you want to reach out
and all usually sells they are working
on an account
and inside an account they have a buying
committee they have few people that they
can reach out to
and create and you know this lobby for
their product
and zoom in for it's not connecting you
only to one person
it's connecting you to your buying
committee inside an account
it's showing you accounts that are
localized to account that you
have been successful with selling to um
it gives you scoops every day online
scopes
and information about events and it's
connected to additional tools that you
are using
like your sales force your marketing
automations
and we have chrome extension that will
go with you wherever you browse
um um online and
basically to have the zoom in for data
with you
everywhere you are you don't need to go
to linkedin and search for a person
and see his data and be dependent on
if he updated or not it's everything
everywhere and it sounds and you can go
ahead
and you can have actions upon it so you
can trigger actions you can build
workflows
you can say every time a new vp of sales
being promoted
in the um
california area of companies that their
revenue is more than 100 million dollars
put them inside the workflow send them
an email from me
and which is amazing it's a time saving
it's it's an amazing automation
right and i think you know for from a
young entrepreneur's perspective there's
a few ways to look
at what zoom info does and obviously the
very you know
surface level way of looking at it is it
just it helps you you know send more
emails helps you do more cold calls to
more personalized people but but to me
you know i'm looking at this in a
difference in a different layer saying
you know i'm going to do you know if i'm
selling and if i have to
you know grow my company and and reach
more people i'm gonna do this anyways
the question is how do i do to the right
people and it's actually you know a
two-sided street
i is a consumer somebody who's being
sold to
i want to receive the messages from
those that are actually relevant to me
so zooming for it sounds like you're
actually treating both sides of the
market both to the people that are
selling
but also to the people that are buying
because if if they're getting a message
through zoom info it's more likely to be
a more relevant message because of the
relevant criterion
because if 10 other companies that are
similar to me purchase this product
well maybe this is something that i
should that i should consider for myself
and that makes a lot of sense now tal
you joined
zoom info marketing and product
operations
today your vp of product growth walk me
through the last
four and a half years growing within
this
organization this big organization now
what is that like
how do you grow from marketing and
product operations to director of
to director in this field all the way to
vp of product growth
um sure it's a great question and it's a
you zoom in for it's a really unique
unique place that allows you to grow
that way
um almost year over year to be promoted
i never felt that i have any glass
ceilings above me
and something is um and denying me from
being promoted like i told you at the
beginning
my role started from numbers from build
building
pipelines of numbers and tracking
conversion rates
and identify opportunities and every
time we saw an opportunity or we fixed a
problem
and my role expanded to be the owner of
that problem that
we just fixed or to be the owner of the
tool that we just
implement and from numbers from
analytics it's
really fast became more of an
operational role
um and we with the role of
operation you have the ability to to be
everywhere
you have the the opportunity to support
everyone with reaching their targets
with understanding where we are going
as an organization where we are going is
marketing and product departments
on what we are going to be measured on
and what are the needles that we want to
move
and and as operations you basically
support the team to
to to achieve those targets and to move
those needles so i started to build
teams
teams of different professionalities to
support
every step of the marketing funnel and
of the product funnel
so for example we had analytics team we
had website development team we had
more of a business application team
that's supporting implementation of
tools
and and as the company grow the
responsibilities grow
and and it's for sure been an amazing
journey and
an amazing place to be when every time
we are growing from acquisition to an
acquisition from emerge to
to a more um how how the leadership is
trusting
us and letting us be responsible on more
and more fields
and letting us experiment things that we
think
will work and if they are not working
it's okay we can fail if we are learning
from our mistakes
and and it's it's kind of
it's i can't point exactly
on on what and made it
um be such a good
and um growth in my specific role
but it's definitely connected to the
growth of the company as the company
growth and as we continue to support the
growth of the company from the marketing
and from the product operational side
and they're all just expanded and
what has it been like for you you know
growing within the organization as a
leader
right you're starting off um you know in
a position you're the seventh employee
which has its
you know innately it comes with
leadership responsibilities
merely as being a seventh employee in
the israeli in the israeli branch
but now that you're leading a lot of
other people and you're and you've grown
into that leadership role over time
what has it been like for you personally
um it's been amazing if you would ask me
five years ago
if i see myself as vp of something or
even a director of something
in such a successful company i will
probably say no no chance in hell
i'm a mother i have two boys and not
i will not find a company that will
support me being a mom
and my career no chance in hell
um and also how can i combine how can i
combine being a mom
and and having a career and
it kind of happened it kind of happened
as step by step it's again it started
from
a mom position i was working until four
i was
living uh 15 minutes before for every
day to pick up my kids
and then as the responsibility grow so i
started to join meetings after they go
to bed and
i saw that people are trusting me and
trusting
my word and giving me more and more
responsibility
and i started to notice this that as i
have more responsibility on the job
as i do more amazing things that i'm
enjoying of
and i becoming even a better mom so even
if i'm one hour less with them
when i am with them i am like much there
i'm much more fulfilled i'm having much
more fun with them i'm appreciate the
time that i have with them
and i managed to find that balance of
having a career
and being a mom and and being a much
better mom
because i have like this all other life
of of zoom info and i never
imagined that i will manage i never
manage
imagine that i will manage that amount
of people
or will be responsible on so many things
in the company
and i still can't like um
can't really understand the size i just
know that we are having fun
and they know that we are growing and i
know that
um i love all the people that work
around me my
reports my peers my managers and it
definitely makes it much easier
that that that's incredible i hope i
answered your question 100
you know this counter-intuitive
statement you know even though i may be
spending
a little bit less time than before
because you're more fulfilled
you know and you have this you know rich
full life
with a lot of responsibilities the time
that you do spend is filled with
happiness with
with fulfillment and and i think that's
that's just an amazing concept in
general you know
both i'm guessing for parenthood and not
something that i have too much to know
about but
but but in general you know this idea of
time business
fulfillment time at the end is a matter
of uh
you know the way you experience and live
in the moment and i'm guessing that as
you're more fulfilled outside you're
better able to live in the moment right
yes and it's also
helped me helps me to much more
appreciate
um my work and my road inside zooming
for because at the beginning i was
oh my god i hope it's okay that i'm
going home at four i hope it's okay that
i picking
up my kids i hope it's okay that i need
to leave because
i have this and that and i was i was
like feeling that
i hope my employer is okay with me being
a mom but
really quickly i understand that my
employer
is amazing with me being the mom and
really supporting me with finding the
balance
and never holding me from being promoted
because i'm a mom
vice versa um um they appreciate
how i can balance how i can multitask
how i can be
in two places and really be in the two
places at once
and and and it i never felt that it
holding
me back what what is something that you
learned throughout these experiences and
you've had this for quite some time and
you've
grown with this experience to a lot of
other people you know both
men and women uh today obviously as more
men also take paternity leave
for a substantial amount of time and and
and you know the the
the expectation of being at home you
know at least for myself when i'll have
kids one day i'm expecting myself to be
there just as much as
you know my future wife will be there
what what is something that you learned
about balancing your time
whether it's about your personal
feelings or the way you
simply you know time manage that you
think would be relevant for a lot of
other people
i think um having the ability to manage
your own time
and for me for example it was really
helpful
no one attract how much hours i'm on the
floor or how much
hours my laptop is online and i
i am tracked on um
getting things done on understanding
what i need to do what my team needs to
do and to make sure that we are doing
that and it's okay if we will start at
10 a.m
it's okay if we will go to pick up the
kids at four it's okay if we will take
few days
off but we understand what we need to do
as a group we understand
what are our deadlines we understand
what is the road
and that will take us there and we can
commit to times
and and basically go and achieve it and
this is why i think that
having work-life balance it's really
individual it's how
you define the balance that you need if
you need to go to the gym for three
times a week
cool go please go if you need to pick up
your kids three times a week
go have fun do that as long as you
understand what is expected from you
and you are doing that and you are able
to manage your own time and be flexible
with your time
and for sure zooming for like that is
the culture
that is our culture we are looking for
people and we are hiring people
and i know that i'm like that so it's
easier for me
that are able to manage their own or on
time
that can be self-managed managers for
themselves
i love it there's there's so much more
that i want to talk about you know
whether it's you know the place that
zoom info is moving to next or
or or you know 2021 and how it's
becoming more and more relevant you know
i think that there's
you know a lot of ways that it's very
trivial why it's you know as in the
hyper-connected world
uh and you know obviously zoom info is
is positioned
in an in amazing place as as more and
more people are
both selling online virtually connecting
with people around the world
aside from their geographical barriers
but i do have a few fun questions
for this episode are you ready yes i
am all right so what is
one of your favorite subjects in middle
school or high school
for sure it was literature okay um
yes i really liked it i even did like
five points of
the the pagoda exam in literature
and i want to say it was a combination
of the teacher
and um you know the experience of
reading a book
of going to another dimension while you
are reading it
of experience and someone else's
thoughts
or someone else's feelings and feel
connected to it or not feel connected to
it
so you know just just to disappear for a
couple of hours and read the book
um i love it i wish i i had more time to
read
but i when i was in high school
i had more time uh to read during the
literature
and studies so amazing for sure my
favorite
one of your role models or somebody that
inspires you
on a regular basis you
you will you will have um and i'm sure
that it's a pretty unique role matter
a role model and but i'm addicted to the
kardashians
and so my role will be
kris jenner the mom okay
and i i think she's amazing i think she
is an entrepreneur she is an inspiration
for me of
how to do business and how to manage
business and how to set people for
success
she build an empire from basically
having kids
and and which is amazing i love her
personality
i love how she do business i love how
she push for things
and so so for me she's the role model
i'm trying to convince our marketing
team to bring her as a speaker to the
zooming for summit i hope it will work
for me
well that that does that that is
surprising
and uh but i love it nonetheless and
what are three words that you would use
to describe yourself
and for sure it's let's have fun
and nothing that we are doing is not
worth
if we are not enjoying from it and if
it's not connecting us
if if we are not having fun right we can
talk about growth we can talk about
personal growth we can talk about
professional growth
but it's not worth it if we are not
enjoying it so if you will come to visit
us in the office you will always see me
walking on the floor and
screaming yella let's have fun and
let's enjoy it every release should be a
party
every success should be a party every
failure we should learn from it and then
have a party and so for sure for sure
um i'm trying to to to put the fun into
everything that we do
this was great amazing
journey
you know coming into zoom info 200
people
seventh employee in israel growing now
to being
a you know 1800 the the personal journey
you know as a mother with the time
management and and the culture that
you've built
and you're a part of uh it sounds
amazing
and uh it sounds really really great and
thank you for taking the time to do this
i know how busy you are
and stay safe and stay healthy thank you
very much for having me
thank you take care thank you